President Obama's dramatic announcement,...
I think same-sex couples should be able to get married.
...elicited a decidedly mixed reaction at the capital.
House Democratic leader Nancy Pelosi had nothing but praise.
Yesterday was quite historic for all of us.
America's children and families and workers saw history being made right before their very eyes;...
...the President of the United States advancing civil rights in our country.
Republican lawmakers derided the President's comments as the wrong message at the wrong time.
House Speaker John Boehner...
...I believe that marriage is the union of one man and one woman.
And the President, the Democrats, can talk about all of this all they want.
But the fact is, the American people are focused on our economy, and are asking the question, "Where are the jobs?"
Opposition to gay rights is often expressed in religious terms.
But representative Pelosi, a Roman Catholic, says her faith leads her to a different conclusion.
My religion compels me and I love it for it to be against discrimination of any kind in our country.
In the Senate, Republicans were mostly silent on the issue.
Minority leader Mitch McConnell stressed the need to create jobs and spur economic growth.
Democratic senator Jack Reed issued a statement endorsing same-sex marriage.
Another Democrat, majority leader Harry Reed indicated he would support legalizing same-sex marriage...
...if the issue were put to voters in his home state of Nevada.
Reed also predicted this year's Democratic party platform will back marriage rights for gays and lesbians.
Meanwhile, President Obama's reelection campaign issued an advertisement...
...pointing out presumptive Republican presidential nominee Mitt Romney's opposition to same-sex marriage.
I do not favor marriage between people of the same gender.
The Obama campaign ad lists benefits and opportunities currently denied to gay couples.
Obama campaign officials say financial donations from gays and lesbians have skyrocketed since the president's announcement.
Michael Burman, VOA News, the Capital.